not only did he write the rules but some
of his staff say they did warn him about
attending the party on the 20th of may
2020.
now i've heard the prime minister's very
carefully crafted response to that
accusation
it's almost sounds like a lawyer wrote
it
so i'll be equally careful with my
question
when did the prime minister first become
aware that any of his staff had concerns
about the 24th of may party
mrs mr speaker i'm i'm grateful to write
all the john for uh repeating the
question that he's uh that he's already
we we have
answered mr speaker uh that it is for
the inquiry to to come forward uh with
an explanation of what happened and i'm
afraid he simply he simply must wait but
he asked about my staff mr speaker he
asked he asked about uh my staff and
what my staff are doing what the and
what they uh have told me and i can tell
him mr speaker that they have taken
decisions throughout this pandemic uh
that that he has that he has opposed to
open up in in july mr speaker as i've
said to mount the fastest vaccine
rollout in in europe
and mr speaker to double the speed of
the booster rollout with the result that
we have the most open economy in europe
mr speaker and we have and we have more
people in employment and more employees
on the payroll now than there were
before the pandemic began that is what
my staff have been working on in downing
street mr speaker and i'm proud of them
[Applause]
so mr speaker apparently sue grey is
going to tell the prime minister when he
first became aware that his staff had
concerns about the mate 20
uh the prime minister's account gets
more extraordinary with each version of
his defense if the prime minister's new
defense were true
it requires him to suggest that his
staff are not being truthful when they
say they warned him about the party
it requires the prime minister to expect
us to believe that whilst every other
person who was invited on the 20th of
may to the party was told it was a
social occasion he alone was told it was
a work meeting
it also requires us
requires the prime minister
to ask us to accept that as it as he
waded through the empty bottles and
platters of sandwiches he didn't realize
it was a party
does the prime minister realize how
ridiculous that sound
[Applause]
mr speaker uh i've said what i've said
about
the events in number 10 uh he will have
to he will have to wait uh for he'll
have to wait through what and and mr
speaker i think i think you know he asks
for uh for further clarification i think
a lot of people who are interested i say
this entirely and passing mystery lots
of people are interested in the exact
legal justification uh from the learning
malaria
leader of the opposition uh
further picture of him drinking a pint
of beer or a bottle of beer
i'm nearly perhaps perhaps perhaps he
could tell the house about that in a
minute in a minute mr speaker but what i
can't what i can what i can tell the
house is that uh throughout the pandemic
people in across government have been
working flat out to protect the british
public uh with a huge quantities of pbe
so we can now make 80
in this country with the biggest and
most generous furlough scheme virtually
anywhere in the world and the fastest
and by the way mr speaker if we listen
to them if we listen to them we would
have stayed in the european medicines
agency and we would never have been able
to deliver the vaccine rollout at the
speed that we did
here
mr speaker if the primary thinks the
only accusation he faces that he once
had a beer with the takeaway then
operation save big dog is in deeper
trouble than i thought
if a prime minister misleads parliament
should they resign
[Applause]
so miss mr speaker let's be absolutely
clear uh the right honourable gentleman
is continuing to ask a series of
questions which he knows will be fully
addressed
by the inquiry he is wasting he is
wasting this house his time he's wasting
the people's time mr speaker he
continues to be completely irrelevant uh
mr speaker
[Applause]
because we have an inquiry we have an
inquiry mr speaker and i and i'm not
going to anticipate that inquiry any
further what i what i can tell him is
that it is because of the judgments that
were taken in downing street because of
the willingness of the british people
to put trust by the way mr speaker in
those judgments and to come to come to
come forward in huge numbers to get
vaccinated which people did and i thank
them for it for the bottom of my heart
people did that because they listened to
our messages mr speaker and it was a
result of that that we now have the
fastest growing economy in the g7 and
i'm at youth unemployment which he ought
to care about youth unemployment at a
record low
[Applause]
i know it's not going well prime
minister but look on the bright side at
least the staff at number 10 know how to
pack a suitcase
mr speaker
last year
last year her majesty the queen sat
alone when she marked the passing of the
man she'd been married to for 73 years
she followed the rules of the country
that she leads
on the eve of that funeral
a suitcase was filled with booze and
wheeled into downing street a dj played
and staff parted late into the night
the prime minister has been forced to
hand an apology to her majesty the queen
isn't he ashamed that he didn't had in
his resignation at the same time
mr speaker i i understand why the uh
right honourable gentleman continues to
politicize she was
sorry
we normally would not and quite rightly
mention the royal thing
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't get into discussions on the
royal family
well in that case mr speaker i must ask
the right honourable gentleman to
withdraw it
i've dealt i've dealt with it
here's starman
if you are
[Applause]
we don't want to go through that again
i'll make the decisions
the answer is that the next question i'm
going back to kirsten to ask his final
question
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker whilst the prime
minister wastes energy defending the
indefensible people's energy bills are
rocketing labour has a plan to deal with
it act vat for everyone provide extra
support for the hardest hit and pay for
it with a one-off tax on oil and gas
companies a serious plan for a serious
problem
what's the government offering
nothing
too distracted by their own chaos to do
their job
while labour was setting out plans to
heat homes he was buying a fridge to
keep the party wine chilled
while we were setting out plans to keep
bills down he was planning parties and
while we were setting out plans to save
jobs in the steel industry he was
he was trying to save just one job
his
own doesn't the country deserve so much
better than this out of touch out of
control out of ideas and soon to be out
of office prime minister
mr speaker
i'll tell you what this government has
been doing to look after the people of
this country throughout this pandemic
and and beyond uh we have been cutting
the cost of living helping them with the
the living wage we've been we've been
raising uh we've been raped we've been
cutting taxes for people on low pay mr
speaker we've been increasing payments
for people uh suffering the costs of
fuel
can i just say to run in here
our constituents wants to hear
the questions and the answers the great
british public
the members of this united kingdom which
you're representing
they need to hear please let's hear the
questions answers prime minister speaker
we will continue to look after people
throughout this uh pandemic and and
beyond but we've also mr speaker i've
been cutting crime by ten percent
putting eleven thousand more police
officers already i told you record home
building last year
more homes than at any time in the last
30 years we are building 40 new
hospitals
think of it broadband has gone up from
nine percent coverage in our country to
65 already and as i said already i think
three times or four times today we have
more people more employees on the
payroll now than before the pandemic
began and uh and unemployment youth
unemployment at a record low mr speaker
when the history of this pandemic comes
to be written and the history of the
labour party comes to be written and
believe me they are history and will
remain history mr speaker it will show
it will show it will show that we
delivered while they dithered and we
we vaccinated while they vacillated mr
speaker
and the reason we've been able to lift
restrictions faster than any other
country in europe and we have the most
open economy and the most open society
in europe mr speaker is thanks to the
booster rollout and thanks to the work
of staff
up and down whitehall across government
throughout the nhs mr speaker and i am
intensely proud of what this government
has done